Don't do it.
So, how does it look like?
Sorry, I'm a little distracted. Just checked, taking a look at something here. Sorry about that.
Oh, OK.
I was just saying how the day looks like.
Alright, it's won't have.
I have a lot, I have a lot to do, I have a lot to do, to do something.
But also for this and this some planning as well, so yeah.
Ashish.
I have it, and you?
Yep, perfectly fine. I have back-to-back meetings, so this Thursday doesn't look like Thursday. Waiting for Friday, let's see how it goes.
The.
Key.
I guess.
So Mike, we haven't meet you before, although I know that you lead the level 2 teams. And I guess when we had the level 2 engineer with you guys, so I was thinking, good morning, Kris.
Good morning.
Morning, Karine.
How are you?
I'm good, thank you.
Great. So, yeah, I was hearing from Jason that, you know, you would have feedback for the engineers at that time, but it's good that finally meeting you here. Yeah, so looking forward to meeting you more on these meetings.
Absolutely.
Alright, so I guess, Manu, is he gonna join or?
I'm not sure. We've been working on invoicing for the last few days. So he might still be caught up with some of that.
Okay.
We do, we do have, it's kind of tight where we do have like the first week in the next month to handle invoicing and finish that up, so I would I would play the weekend and I actually got mine mostly done, yeah.
But even so, I still took, I still took him once on Monday to do the rest, but yeah, so it goes sometimes. And Jacob Richardson, I think he should be joining us. He's probably, we're early, we're early. We're all early today, so we'll give him a couple of minutes.
That's completely fine. We have more time to discuss about the engineers and plan on the things.
I had sent a request for the May leave planner so that that could help us out as we need to with our understanding of who's off when. Because I know we just had, you know, an overlap technically with Ronan who is out.
Yep.
Well, and we saw that, right, for me. So we have that visibility. So I just want to get for the entire of me what that would look like as well. Thanks.
Sure. Morning, Jacob.
It.
Sarbjeet.
Morning, gentlemen. Hey, Jason. Hello, Jacob. Hi, Mike. Hello, Karine. How are you all?
Warning.
Fantastic, thanks for asking.
Good, yeah.
So, uh, Jason, uh, I have replied to your email. As of now, we don't have anyone who has planned any leaves for the month of May, so we are good there.
Good.
Yeah.
I'm good, I'm good.
Yep, yeah. And I have this message instructed to the team that before 25th of every month, let me know about the leave for the next month. So we are aligned there. So yeah, that's why I did not email you. But I'll take the ownership going forward that if even if there are no leaves, I'll still let you know for that.
Rick.
Yeah.
We all are on the same page.
Okay, yeah, yeah, just good to know for us to keep track of it. That's good. That's a good overview for me, technically, yeah.
Yep, that's right. And I just, since we have you here, I would like to quickly discuss about the upcoming holiday that we have for May 18th, which is for Canada, and May 25th, which is for US, the US Memorial Day.
Although engineers are allowed to take only one of the two optional holidays, so just want to understand, like, are you comfortable giving them an off on 18th or on 25th, or you want to split so that you have coverage?
Hoh.
That is a good question. We're off on the 18th for sure, as this would be most of our customers. The 25th we won't. So if I had to make a choice on it, and I'll let Megan and Jacob
You know, voice their, put their vote or cast their vote as well, but I would say take them the 18th off.
Yeah.
In general, for all of them, rather than split.
Yeah, I agree.
Mhm.
Yeah, yeah. But it's a good question. You may be posed to think into that, but yeah, I think that's a good idea because all of us will be off and then the after hours person assigned will cover as necessary should there be any concerns anyhow. So I think we're good.
Okay.
Yep.
Okay, let me just take a note of this just a moment.
Just.
I don't have any planned leave myself for me. Though if things come up, I'll probably ping and let you all know.
Haight.
Mister Richardson will be off for the last two weeks in May, just so you all know.
Is where are you planning to travel, Jacob?
I am going to Japan for two weeks.
Oh, nice, nice.
Paul.
Yeah, so very excited. I haven't done any traveling, so be a first time for me. Good to experience a different culture, so.
It depends, sounds like a place where you would want to go for the holiday.
True, true.
Yeah, lots of good food. That's what I'm most excited about.
You.
I agree.
Yeah.
Yeah, Mike, you have any Lee planned?
For me.
No, not that I know of right now. Nothing's scheduled out for me. No plan leaves.
Yeah, yeah, so you see, so while Jacob is off, I'll shoulder his responsibilities and the interactions with you all as necessary. OK.
Yeah, sure.
Key.
Um, yeah, we can get, we can get going 'cause I don't think Mirror is is is a...
is joining us if you wanted to.
Yep, Mayur just messaged me that he's joining in 5 minutes, so I think we can.
Hoh.
Okay. General feedback, we had a session and I don't think I talked to Jacob Richardson about it, but I filled out those surveys to get feedback on the engineers and the attention to detail is something that I mentioned, especially as it relates to time entries.
I would say there are varying updates that are given, sometimes very early in the morning. Ronan gives very good detailed updates in a time entry, but late in the day that kind of becomes less.
So, you know, so he's capable right in terms of that, but in particular, the OS batching tickets we saw where the correct work role and agreements were being selected, which you know prompts us to for it to look like as it should be built.
So we had reiterated that. So I wanted to make sure that when we coach that multiple times already. So I wanted to reinforce that point that we do need to see some improvement on that going forward. Okay.
Sure. So regarding the work role update, so I have cascaded this to the entire team. I have a question. When we select the work role administrative type, does it change the associated agreement too or agreement has no effect to it if we change the workflow?
I don't think that they are, when you change one, it immediately affects the other, right? It doesn't cascade that change down. It's not, one is not dependent on the other. So you would have to select the correct agreement and type. That should also hint.
Yep.
To them, as if they should be working on a ticket or not, because I so not necessarily a habit, but sometimes, and something we have to clean up on our end too, where a customer who is no longer a customer might call in and they might do some work for them, or you know, and...
Mhm.
And I could understand where they might have known that customer and said, okay, yes, I will do whatever ticket and not realizing that they went off boarded. That's something that we have to clean up internally and I've escalated that so that we can get those customers cleaned up on out of the way and easily noted.
that we shouldn't be servicing those customers. So that's on austerity remedy so that the engineers don't fall into that category. Okay.
Yep.
Yep, I, I recall it did happen with one of the engineers, I guess, when it was active in IT glue and engineer did work on it, yeah.
Yeah, and I saw it too. I saw it too. It's only when I had to dig deep into the agreement and see that the additions were expired, but the agreement wasn't. So yes, I, for me, it looked as though the customer was an active one. So I agree with their assessment on it too. So it's something that we definitely need to clean up on our end.
Yep.
All right, thank you so much, Jason, for sharing that. So in reference to the end time of the engineers when they are logging in and at what time they are available into the call queue, for my end, what I'm trying to do to track if they are logging in on time is they're updating me the time the moment they log into the call queue.
Here.
drag this option to active and then was tool. Is there any other way that I can possibly track if they are logged into the queue other than this option that I came up with?
Not that I know of.
Not that I, not that I know of, um, honestly, uh, you know, outside of of adding an additional...
license or role for you, you know, like creating a user for you on our end, which I don't think we have that right now. There's no way that you get that visibility of who else might be on. I will check to see if there are like reports as well too, so that...
It lines up with what you're seeing on understanding, um, so, but we historically wouldn't be real-time if it's a report, right?
Sure. Good morning, Manu.
Maybe, maybe I can give that as well, yeah.
Do we have any read-only access or at least without incurring extra cost on the license just to have the live update?
I don't think so. I don't think so because it's, I don't think, I'll ask a question, but it's tied to Microsoft Teams as well in your login. So I'll find out. I'll find out.
Yep, yep.
Yes, sure. Good morning, Mayur.
Good morning, Mayur.
Hey, good morning. Nice to see everyone after a while.
Nice to see you too. It's a long time.
How are you doing?
Yeah, good, good. Just, yeah, it's a new year for us. A lot of, you know, a lot of admin tasks internally and then also client side as well, making some good progress mainly on the London office where three of our resources are posted. Akhilesh, Harish and recent addition.
Yeah.
Yes.
So, for Rodge, so yeah.
Not for us.
Great, thank you. So, Mayur, we were just discussing about the call queue. We were discussing about if there is any mechanism that I can track to see if any changes are into are logged into the call queue. So, I guess, Jason, as you mentioned that some sort of reporting.
Mm.
that would help at what time they are into the queue. But there is another catch. So when engineers are going on an outbound call, they are manually required to change their option to inactive so that they don't get any call parallelly, which would eventually miss because they are on an outbound call already.
This is something that I would be able to track if I'm given some limited access at least to what they are doing in the call queue and if they are on an outbound call or on an inbound call. At least this will empower me to.
Yeah.
to manage their productivity in the call queue effectively.
Right, Jason, for I believe.
Yeah.
That's the thing, right? Like we are, if an agent is on call, then they can still can get a call based on the routing policies we have at the moment.
You mean if they, sorry, if they don't have a license, is what you're asking?
No, no, so for our technicians, like if they are on the blueware working and then they get a call, they answer the call from the queue, they can still get the second call that is coming in while they are on call with a user.
Yes.
Only from through Teams, yes, through the QA, no.
Okay.
Right, so they can get, they can get a call if they get a direct call, they can get a direct call, or if we call in, you know, within our tenant as well, you technically can.
Makes sense, yeah.
Right.
Why?
Rick.
Why do you ask?
Yeah, I believe that was, well, Ashish, that's what what were you mentioned, like first phase of your thing.
Yeah, that was for outbound call, not for the inbound, because for inbound, I know automatically they don't get any call, but for when they are making an outbound call, they have to manually change their status to inactive so that they don't get any other incoming call.
Okay, makes sense.
Mm.
Yeah, you know, that's a good point. That's a good point.
That's something we'll have to just we'll have to see in Luware in our flows if there is something we can we can do there as I'm testing Luware right now for the London office. I think that is a good point as well.
Well, I saw something, but I never tested it myself. I'm just going to share my screen for a sec. So, this is one of the views that they may see, right, on Luware. So, technically, if you go to call on behalf,
Sure.
Yeah.
Right, it, and so it obviously will use this. That's the overall calling number that you see. It should, it should technically call from Luware and be recorded within Luware as well.
Key.
Right.
Okay.
So I want to test that out before, I have never tested it, but I assume that the functionality was there, but I never delved into it. But if this works, then technically the engineer won't have to go.
Mm.
Inactive, they can stay active and make calls through this, so we know what's happening with them, and as they come off that call, they can get another call, etc., right? Because sometimes that removes that entire risk of...
of them getting a call while they're on another call, as you're saying, if they haven't put themselves inactive, as well as it gives us visibility to know, okay, they're on an outbound call, which is an inbound call, but we still would see them in a queue, quote unquote, right?
So we can test that and see how that works, if my hypothesis is correct. And yeah, if that's the case, then it's a lot easier for us to manage and maintain those reasons within the way.
Yep.
Yeah.
Jacob, what do you think?
Yes.
Did you ever test that by chance? I didn't even ask.
I haven't tested it personally. I would like to try to play around with it first before I give an opinion.
Okay.
Key.
Yeah, so we'll test it and see if that if that works. If that's the case, then that's great.
Yeah, the second part is reporting, so one one way is giving Ashish the license, another just so I believe we can test some automations there for lower reporting, like on a daily or whatever frequency we would like.
Yeah.
That would help everyone.
I haven't see, I haven't seen any functionality directly in Lua that that speaks to having that email of our reports going out.
Hmm.
So, I thought we could have a discussion with the people on it.
Yeah.
Yes, I'm already testing Luware for London so that those things will also come up when we implement there for London because we have ITBD by design team there as well. So I just want to ensure that these feedbacks we are looping in and working on improvements as well for that queue.
The reporting outside of Luware through grabbing the data and putting it into Power BI is something that we have as well too, technically from Luware already, because they probably did their shortcomings in terms of that. It's not that we're publishing it though, those Power BI reports.
Hmm.
Kour.
SK.
so that it could be scheduled out, right, or refreshed. So from that perspective, that ecosystem is not non-existent. But that being said, if technically if they did have the...
Right.
Mm.
G.
Millimeters.
Kip.
We could probably do it on a weekly basis and share it as necessary.
Yep.
Yeah.
Ashish, for the frequency, from your feedbacks and everything, what helps you the best for what you were looking for?
Okay.
I think, I think daily reports would be helpful.
Yeah.
Right, so Jaisal, we can do some tests on the automations on reporting, just to see what data we are getting out, and we can then share some examples with Ashish to see if that's something we can use.
So...
You have access to reporting on the way.
Both.
I have just in the test environment, I have that. So just for the testing, we are doing it at the moment. That is, again, we can check with David Peebles to see how we can automate those.
It.
Haight.
And Mayur, just adding to your point, the reporting will definitely be helpful. However, if we can have some live data available, that's what we were discussing with Jaisal without incurring any extra cost on the license part, that will be more beneficial for all of us. Ashish will have the real-time visibility. He can go ahead and talk to the engineer straight away.
Mm.
You could try.
Right.
ensure that they are available in the queue.
My.
Okay, yeah, that's something that also we can we can test if we can just have like a, you know, read-only type license, if that's something what Laroia is doing, we can definitely, yeah, review that.
Yes.
The.
Yep, yep.
Yep.
You can be fantastic, you can be fancy.
Rick.
All right, before we proceed further, Manu, I had a discussion which is still regarding the holiday, upcoming holiday of May 18th and 25th. So I just wanted to know what do you want for your people? Do you want them to take an off on the 18th or 25th or do you want to split?
Yes.
For me, we do observe the Victoria Day that is 18th, or just like quickly confirm 18th, right? So, yeah, that those like that they will have offices closed, so if we can have for both and London offices, so free resource and then Sandhu as well.
City.
18th.
Yes.
If we can target that date, that would be better.
Vaid.
OK, so May 18th would be an off for JSL and may use spot and 25th be working for all of them.
Yep.
Okay, got it.
Thank you so much. Just in case, by 18th, if anything comes up, any change of plans, feel free to email us and we can accommodate the required changes and we will have our people for the coverage.
Sure.
In.
Okay, sounds good.
Q.
Any other feedback or suggestions for the Engineering?
Well, good. I am reviewing the feedbacks today, tomorrow. The CSAT we get back. Last month we had...
I mean, but...
So, we, we are like in bright gauge, we are monitoring 30 days rolling for for CSAT, so those ones that I'm I was concerned about has fallen off from our our our current view at the moment. However, we can't get to the previous ones.
Okay.
So I'm just reviewing that mainly for Akhilesh. We got a higher number for last month, but just due to the time constraint, I wasn't able to get the bottom of that and have those conversations with the clients. So I'm just reviewing that and any feedback that comes out of that, we'll share it with you, Ashish, so we can work on improvements there.
Sure. Thank you so much, Mayor. Since you brought this CSAT piece, I will, I get this weekly report. It is automated by Jeremy. And towards the end of the month, I get a monthly report as well. So for entire April month, I have received the CSAT survey for Engineers. Let me quickly share my screen.
Yes.
Sure.
And we can just go through it.
I hope it's visible to you.
Yeah.
Okay, so here if you see, this is for Harish, we have received one negative C set, 6 positive. For Akhilesh, we have 12 positive C sets, one negative. This is for entire April.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Let me check what date range I had for, like, I believe there were four negative reviews in total that we were seeing on the right gate side for CSAT. Not sure if that was like, because it's rolling, so not at this moment, not sure. It's just April or it was like end of March and like mid-range or something, so we can.
So.
S.
Possibly, possibly, yes.
We can definitely look on that. So as soon as I have some feedback, we'll connect with you, Ashish, so we can see if there is, personnel-wise, if we can make any upgrades there. Or it's a system challenge.
Absolutely, I'll wait for the feedback there for you. Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Jesse, anything from your side on the similar lights?
Um, let me do a quick check on the CX.
While Jaisal is loading that, one feedback I would share is we were focusing on the call answer rate at London. That was a big challenge. And last couple of weeks, I believe.
On 95% plus calls are being answered, so I'm really happy with that. So the team is working really well in conjunction with our on-site team at our London team. So that's really good.
Thank you.
Good job.
It's good, man. Good job. I am.
Actually, all of them so far, Ronan's of all positive feedback, yeah, the responses from our reactions from customers are positive for Ronan.
You know, Karine in particular.
Has like twenty-three.
Positive responses.
As opposed to the others who might have like two and three. No, no, seriously. So that's a that's great. That's great, yeah.
That's Kip.
Yeah.
That's a great thing, yeah. Jason, on that, on that particular note, current, right?
Yep.
The.
Can we build a trend like what's working there? So we can just do a positive reinforcement on that with the rest of the technicians, both with IT by Design and RL1s as well, that what's working. That's something, a monthly activity I do for both London and Guelph, and what worked, what's not working. One of the most common is feed.
how fast we can get to them and how fast we can give them updates on their issue, not resolution, but just updates. If there is anything else that is showing up trend-wise, we can just positively reinforce with the team that this is working. Let's follow that.
S.
Yeah.
That's a great idea, Manu.
Sure.
Yeah, Jess, if you have time after to discuss that, take a look. We can build something out together.
Sounds good.
Jessil, are you pulling the the CSAT report or?
Yeah, well, it's a Bright Gate just live that we have right now.
OK.
Do you get those right now?
Do you get the or no?
I only get the I only get the automated report weekly every Monday.
Okay.
For which, which was automated by Jerome.
Okay, okay, yeah. Well, it'll be from the same sources. Well, I'm getting mine from that.
Ash, let's ensure we give a shout out to Karine for the way he's taking care of the things. Definitely, the impact is there.
I will, I will.
Yep, yep.
For sure, for sure.
Okay, before I jump into the presentation deck, Jason, Mayur, is there anything else that you guys want to share?
No, that's all for now. Thank you.
Okay, thank you so much. Let me share my screen.
Although we have limited time, I quickly go through the important pieces of the presentation.
I hope it's visible to you.
Yeah.
Kip.
It's a test.
Yep. Thank you. The first one is the action tracker. This is where we have the KPIs for the engineer. So I'm getting the reports automated from Jeremy. New engineers like Sir for us and there is another engineer who was added to a different bot.
I have requested these names to be added to the list so that I have a complete picture of the engine's performance. Second action item, this will be on hold for some time, so I can skip it. For the phone queue management, this is still under monitoring, although I have instructed.
technicians to let me know the moment they log into the call queue. But at the same time, as we discussed, some daily reporting or maybe unlimited access would be helpful for me to check it more rigorously so that I can manage the team availability into the call queue.
And last one was the data security and best practices. So engineers who are getting on boarded to MSP Corp, we ensure that they go through the ITBD security best standard practices. There is a module that we have created where every engineer has to go through it. And if
They clear only then we allow them to onboard with you guys. So this is something which is ongoing. It's a regular practice. It happens with every engineer who starts with LSP core.
Any questions, Tim? Yes, Malig.
Ohh, this is uh more internal, so, uh, just so, um, do you know if we are...
We have this ISAT that we are doing internally, right, for like security training and all that. Do we have all the IT by design team members enrolled into that as well? That's something I'll check as well, but if you know on top of your hand.
What training?
Oh.
Our security team runs, you know, that spam email trainings and all that, like we have this campaign running from.
For me.
What's the tool like forgetting the name there?
From know before, yeah?
No before, yes.
Yeah, I'm not sure if they're included in that, but I can ask a question. But I would think that it is default. How it normally is configured in before is once they've been assigned and they're active users on the Microsoft site, that it syncs and that they would get that as well. Yeah, we could pull the Team and see if they're getting those emails.
Blake.
Key.
And then Dale quickly question.
Right.
Yeah.
I'll quickly check with Alvin as well, just to see if that's something he is aware of or not. So Alvin is our security, let's say, lead national-wide. So.
Right.
But yeah, he's our chief security officer.
Chief, Chief Security Officer, yes.
Yeah.
Key.
Uh, uh, I have a hard stop at 11. I have another call for uh, the soft team. So, is it OK if I share the presentation deck in the email?
Sameer.
Yeah.
Yes.
Ohh, for sure, for sure, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's fine.
So I will do that. Thank you so much for joining the call. Thank you so much, Karine, Mayur, Jaisal, Mike, and Jacob for your presence, and looking forward to the next video soon. Have a good day. Thank you, Ashish. Take it too.
Yeah, likewise. Take care. Bye.
Have a great week, everyone. Take care. Bye bye.
Thank you. Thanks, everyone. Bye.